- [Narrator] Education
and food go hand in hand.
And, at one school in a
drought-stricken region of Tanzania,
one garden program has changed
a generation of school kids.
(inspiring music)
♪ Tanzania ♪
(foreign music)
- One, two three.
Gardening club.
- [Narrator] The O'Brien
School has around 360 students.
The majority of whom are
from the Maasai tribe.
An original and nomadic group of people
whose diets traditionally consist of meat,
milk, blood and fat.
Farming and eating
vegetables was not a part
of their lifestyle, but in an
area marked by extreme levels
of poverty and food scarcity,
kids were malnourished, and
their education was suffering.
- [Narrator] So the O'Brien
School did two things:
they started a garden and
began offering two meals a day
using the vegetables they grew.
- [Narrator] The school garden
grows everything from kale
to cabbage, tomatoes, peppers,
okras, sweet potatoes.
And each day the students
are responsible for planting,
tending and harvesting the crops.
- [Narrator] And these
changes are not confined
to the classroom.
Students have taken what
they've learned at school
and brought it home.
Planting gardens with their families
and their local villages,
which is all to say the
the program is working.
(inspiring music)